elodie isadore est la nouvelle
présidente du conseil départemental des
jeunes elle succède à jette ton miettes
qui laisse son fauteuil avec regret
elodie lisa d'or
quel ému d'être enfin d'avoir pu être
élu et je remercie vraiment ce qui nous
font confiance et ceux qui me
soutiennent depuis le début je vous
remercierai jamais assez voilà je suis
fier de ma de l'afld la jeunesse
réunionnaise en l'air c'est vraiment un
honneur d'être deuxième oui je suis
vraiment content parce que je sens
quelque on va prendre demain la relève
après forcément je suis un peu triste
parce que c'est la fin la fin d'un
mandat à la fin d'une ère et
d'investissement mais ce dont je suis
sûr c'est que c'est une fois on peut
être mais c'est une fin vraiment
heureuse et le 10e succès sur et pourra
parfaitement ainsi que les 10 restants
il aura fallu deux tours de scrutin pour
qu'un prénom sorte de l'urne 200
collégiens ont participé à ce vote et
ont plébiscité elodie qui dans son
discours de présentation a su être très
convaincante mais bon sens en passant on
oppose lille on continue à avoir honoré
et tous ensemble avec la baie du
grenelle i qui formons nous visons à
nous mêmes congés et me lancer au monde
antique nous aussi en tant que nous
avons le droit dont la capacité de venir
montrons que nous ses côtés
nous avons évidemment seulement une
assemblée plénière qui s'est déroulée en
présence de la vice présidente en charge
de l'éducation sabrina ramin très
impressionné par les ans des candidats
mais également par l'implication des
jeunes dans la vie publique
bravo et je danse je l'attendais peut
effectivement vous rendre hommage ce
matin vous avez une certaine aisance à
grandeur d'année en année je suis bluffé
bluffé par le talent bluffé par cette
jeunesse qui est en mouvement en action
pour son île on sait tous et l'adulte
savent que cette jeunesse très prise par
leurs activités à l'école et malgré tout
ils souhaitent s'investir s'investir
auprès des anciens auprès de cette
société réunionnaise lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
harcèlement à l'école ou sur les réseaux
sociaux aide aux enfants hospitalisés
les projets ne manquent ou pas les
jeunes en effet très motivés le discours
des candidats reflété d'ailleurs
l'engagement et le rôle actif qu'il
souhaite désormais occupés dans la
société
ce sont souvent handicapés qui sont
hospitalisés et j'aime faire
des journées lors desquelles des
activités seront mises en place la
formulation sur la seconde il y à la
différence d'un harcèlement
psychologique en milieu scolaire ou
harcèlement moral et ou à caractère
sexuel à seulement familiale à ce fonds
numérique et un scénario est tellement
moche et de photographies j'ai même une
action en plein jour les élus
accompagnés d'un photographe et artiste
réussit déjà mais cela pourrait
expliquer entre autres la nouvelle
équipe est élu pour une année les jeunes
pourront compter sur l'appui de la
direction de la vie éducative pas mener
à bien tous leurs projets